you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens welcome back to the game
spot co off stage here at e3 2016
sponsored by lego star wars the force
awakens I'm Chris waters joining me on
stage to talk about our absolute
favorites at e3 this year it's joven
Shire sohinki and lasercorn gentlemen
how's it going very well how are you
great dog at the same time really well
done it's must work together something
anyway everything's at e3 we're gonna go
through this sohinki you're gonna start
us off pick something that like I mean
this is the cream of the crop for you
this is the thing that months from now
you're going to be like III 2016 that
was about this I've been saying it since
I saw the original trailer and now I'm
saying it even more we happy few how
like there's so many games here but how
is this not like on the top of
everyone's list it's ridiculous i watch
that trailer and when I mention it to
people here's what I hear is like oh
yeah the game that like kind of seems
like it's Bioshock yep like yeah the
game that kind of seems like it's
Bioshock a game that look how are you
know more exciting that looks like it
captures the ambiance and the nuance
storytelling of a game that many people
consider to be one of the best of all
time yes now you're about here we're on
the same page yeah Bioshock meats like
1984 it's great his job is literally to
redact stuff just like in the book and
it's one of my favorite books of all
time so I really love that they're
bringing like a bioshock feel to it in
like the way the characters that one
scene in the trailer where all the
characters look at you and they notice
you're like off the joy or whatever like
it's a downer i love the terminology
it's like an equilibrium feel ya instead
of no feelings maybe we'll find out that
the main characters are grandmas on
cleric we don't know ya back grandma
what a reference watching that trailer
and like having that comparison to
bioshock i thought was just so great in
the sense that the bioshock wanted to
were great as we moved into infinite it
had a completely different styles
brighter it was less creepy and scary
and this brings that back to that scary
vibe but it's just like weird
makes you kind of crawl a little like
they're talking about a pinata hit whole
Kenyatta and in you believe yes squish
loves ya so good and it goes in its and
they're all like so happy oh my god it's
just I don't know I don't know what ha
from this game and I'm glad that I don't
know pinata like oh my god I'm either
ran out everyday wear the masks watch me
the reason this hits like even a little
closer to home then the then just all
Bioshock was awesome let's do let's have
some more that is because it seems it's
much more personal so many people are
looking at you so many putting the focus
on you and also the fact that it's like
if you're not taking your joy if you're
sad if you're off your game like you're
ostracize we've all felt like I'm not
feeling I'm not feeling it today I'm not
a good mood I'm dealing down people are
looking at you like hey like we're
cheering your feeling on your feeling on
the outskirt yeah that like that's a
really good enough i guess you right
there and oh I think that's one of the
reasons why and it gets me the entire
trailer like it feels a little off
you're really waiting it's like this
game seems a little too happy right now
and that reveal hits and it is just so
good like it's the way that they build
up to it like they show the pinata and
then they hit into it and then the
player like has his hand there and you
can't see the pinata anymore but now you
hear it looks like they're eating stuff
on the table it's like I'll move your
hand man move your hand move the hand
it's like oh yeah it's well done I I
think one of these happy smiling faces
that just really want to murder you like
really no I do yeah even the security
guys and stuff because they're on the
pill that makes them happy all the time
they make you seem like a threat yeah
alright lasercorn hit me with one of
your favorites from e3 man I am I'm
super psyched for for titanfall 2 and I
know yeah I know that a lot of people
kind of stopped playing titanfall one
and it kind of died out and a lot of
people saying it should have had a
fleshed-out story mode but man I just I
love mech games and met games the best
met games are always the ones where you
could get out of your Mac and you really
feel like you're in something and like I
just had so much fun with titanfall the
only reason I stopped playing it was
because I felt like my friend stop
playing it and moved on to other games
and you like I mean I think that's
that's a criticism it a lot of people
get I'm fine I'm sure if you look at
numbers of player population you know X
months after launch yeah
doesn't compare favorably to like a call
of duty which right people in all year
round but I think in the multiplayer
shooter space there's there's room for
games that like yeah they're hot for a
few months yeah and then it just distill
down to just the core who keep going but
like there was professional titanfall to
being played long after the playerbase I
doubt it'll even for titanfall not Jen
fault you out yeah yeah titanfall so
tight for shadow yeah you know we got
some enthusiasm for titanfall here what
was it excited you about titanfall to
what they showed at the dude more aliens
sword mech that scene where both the the
players eject and you use that whip
thing that they have now to whip them
over apple yeah I like seeing laser
going to get this exciting idea it's a
lot of fun awesome it has those those
like magic moments that you see in games
like Battlefield what it's like that was
awesome I went nuclear with my Mac and
then I killed the guy as he ejected and
did that and that's I love those that's
why I place shooters that's kind of why
I don't play call of duty your games
like that I feel like it doesn't have
those moment at the galmans yeah I would
you say though like it seems like that
the Titans are like a little sentient
and now I'm gonna feel really bad about
myself my buddy go ahead a man but I ops
done more when you punch through one of
them to get the guy out and now you're
killing two people you just heightens
chat it's like I like the typing the
person's gotta go but I like the Titans
with that said I love the the story
element that this is doing now I think
because would add it to be honest when
it comes to grab enough the other mac
i'm not the best I lose to them all the
time so I'm the story player yeah I want
a good story and i think i'm gonna get
that with this game and i can't wait to
do that you can't wait to have your mech
I can't have my mech pick me up and
chuck me like you did at the end
although ultimately I want to be ball
special yeah and I don't see how the
aliens factor into because you got a
quick glimpse of them and in a story
mode you'll get to probably see more
like what planet are we on what powers
do these aliens have and stuff like that
yeah they miss out i think a little bit
in the first one on really having the
interaction with the aliens on the maps
you'd see them every now and then but
it'll be cool to see how they've
expanded up you can shoot them down on
that one desert man like a little bonus
of XP but like yeah definitely seeing
that world flushed out a little bit i
think will be really cool
joven um for me there's two things I
really want to touch on there on both
sides of what III is okay and the first
is it might not even be the best game
that I play in the next year or two
years to Penn when it comes out but i
will remember seeing this trailer
revealed and it was the spider-man game
other play station personnel are so good
you guys like we're sitting there we're
watching it it was me Matt Rob and flits
awesome smosh games and like we're big
comic book nerds and we're looking the
trailer before they reveal I'm like
looks like a spider-man game man would
it be greater they showed a spider-man
game and then they so insomniac games
like dude what insomniac games with a
spider-man game I thought would be so
awesome and then you hear them talking
he's like wait did he just say he's from
Queens here it is and we could you like
we're in an office they were
professional people trying to get a job
done and we just erupt like oh my god
it's spider-man and it's like because
spider-man are there such great
experiences as games and I can't wait to
see insomniac who did a sunset overdrive
and the movement in that game was so
smooth and seamless huh I want to see
that apply to the spider-man game and I
think there's a lot there but I think
honestly when we look back at e3 2016 I
think the thing that should stand out
for years to come is what xbox was doing
at their presentation I know a lot of
people said that PlayStation had the
best presentation because it was game
game game game which they did and
rightfully so that's what people want to
see put the whole xbox play anywhere
where if you download a digital version
on your xbox you can plan on your PC the
cross compatibility that they talked
about last year and now really going 360
like you're seeing all of it now I think
Microsoft is bringing gamers together
you have console gamers you have pc
gamers and it's kind of uniting them
there's still the pc gamers are always
better than in console gamers it's
likely quickly but as I read today get a
mass in a keyboard peripheral yep right
at today about the peripheral coming in
a few months and I just think that's
that's really good that is what I want
to see it III I want to see people
bringing games
that change well the game and I want to
see these people of Microsoft and Sony
changing the industry yeah I think
that's what Microsoft is there the water
has been tested a little bit you have a
street fighter 5 PlayStation players can
play back your pc players brachot league
is now league again and and arguably
those games are better on controller
versus mouse and keyboard so and i think
that the transition we're seen I think
once xbox has some first-person shooters
to announce a release that's when we're
going to see the mouse and keyboard
compatibility because that's when you're
gonna need it yeah absolutely did yeah I
was interesting review highlighted that
because this year you know last year was
a lot about VR and a are messaging app
before that we were sort of in this
still in the new console cycle this year
was kind of low more low-key in terms of
stuff that isn't just pure games but
that's I think that's a great sort of
highlight in terms of yeah like the
industry is evolving it's moving ever
truly Hill doing that one of my
favorites was my favorite last year when
they released the announcement trailer
and it's my favorite again this year
horizon zero dawn yes I am so captivated
by that world by all those creatures and
guerrilla games I really like respect
their pedigree from the kill zone series
I was way into Killzone multi-layer good
and yet seeing to seeing more of a loi
out there using her tools in so many
different ways I just out in the open
world is really getting me hyped yeah
what do you guys think about that go
about dinosaurs man how can you go wrong
they really do just the way they move in
everything does look so cool and you
just you instantly want to know more
about them it's like what how do you
want to win over lasercorn you either do
mex or dinosaur dinosaur things ever was
Dino riders I'm still waiting for the
diner riders are the power what haha
harnessed about dude I know I was a
literal talking about thunder and
forward like never however you born is
found another the lawyers are the crew
loves ya my goodness they could turn
that into a great game right yes I mean
just look at that image that was going
around it became the meme right just
yeah dynasty worse with all that on you
don't know what to put up on the screen
for your Dino writer
verizon with a resin or don't know late
80s Early 90s I guess but it looks
beautiful and rainy its vast and I think
in an innocent in a game that's going to
give you dinosaurs you want something
vastly let map is gigantic and I
potential potential and I think one of
the things they talked about last year
that they didn't show really this year
talk about that much but you are from
one tribe right there are other tribes
in this world and you kind of imagine
like that given this technology that can
be harvested from these creatures
different tribes could take these could
like live substantially different lives
yeah I mean could be in the forest vs in
the ruins of a city could you be using
the technology first like down sort of
different specialization paths what I'm
hearing is multiplayer rumors right 90
riders sec 02 the rumors i 90 riders
right here and that right i really a
dinosaur it's more of a ram but you can
imagine what it would be like if you
were riding a tiger dinosaurs
oscillation is so good like I just tweet
it was like right after we saw the
trailer for this game during the press
conferences I just tweeted out is like
games in 2016 man they're just so pretty
this game is just gorgeous look just
look at that man like it's so awesome to
see just every game coming out your
psyche mind blown every time really I
really great I don't know why when I
when I saw this one I was making a
connection also with recore very
different types of games and different
worlds obviously but there's something
about playing as the character and
having like these beasts or mex if you
work with andrey core i think it's
something that metroid fans are going to
love because if i've heard correctly
some of the creators of metroid prime
have gone to make recore and recall just
looks like a third-person sabes game
yeah in my opinion I mean and it's
interesting because it seems like you
know we're a Samus pursuit was what
transform is sort of like allowed the
different powers now you have the
relationship with all the different you
know configurations of the different
mechs speaking of are these two small DJ
robots they're not technically mext so
it's not real yeah
you don't you don't pilot them so I
don't know if they can read because
everybody right there yeah it's a little
different we'll see we'll see we haven't
seen everything and maybe they are more
MEK like once we see a bigger ones yeah
I was the other time to mention another
game yeah go ahead as my my number two I
think of the show all right poor honor
for all last year it was my game of the
auto I'm talking about the war honor is
going to be so good when I mentioned
this to people a lot of what i hear is
like isn't that just kind of like
multiplayer dynasty warriors and my
answer is first of all no but second of
all wouldn't that be awesome I mean
dynasty Warriors I think they take lumps
because the combat does not feel
personal yeah you are not engaged
one-on-one and you're not reacting to an
enemy's attack and certainly parts of
for honor you're hacking your way
through like the red shirts of that
world yet had red shields red light
connection when you're it locked into a
one-on-one fight yeah we played it yet I
played it last year yeah it is so good
like an interesting Rock Paper Scissors
Bashere opponent in the face mechanic
yeah where it's like you're you're
trying to match his movements while
simultaneously guessing if he's going to
throw out that shield brick and it looks
like they've even expanded on the combat
a little bit we saw that moment where he
he breaks the block of the samurai just
charges him into a rock oh it looks like
each class has their own unique things
that they can do and they've even
expanded on that into this year and it's
such a such a physical game yeah you
know you really feel like you you get
into like yeah a samurai would quite
different than a Viking would quite
different than a night and how they
would they would clash how to feel
different and what kind of yeah
ramifications I would have for the
actual gameplay really intriguing and it
almost feels a little bit like kind of a
melee battlefront almost with the way
aah other players and the way the these
diagnostic
yeah yeah I'm sorry obviously not I'm
sorry i was thinking battlefront 2 yeah
yeah that would be uh also the story
mode it's just like we watch the trailer
and you're like what ties all of this
together and again going back to me
being the story player like I want to
see that connection I want to know what
it is oh there was a cataclysm the world
got real bad I had to fight over water
and they just didn't stop fighting and
then someone say that one biking was
just really thirsty he's like murder
thirsty for blood yes but yeah then
there's the antagonist comes along at
the end yeah yes it'd be a different
kind of fact it kinda entertains I I
don't know what I'm going to get from
this game almost and I like that I know
what the multiplayer is gonna is gonna
be like but what's the story that's what
I want to see more of in yang and I
haven't got a chance to try out the
single player demo but it looks great it
looks really fleshed out I was surprised
I had no idea they were even working on
a single player until until we saw the
press conference where they showed it
and it looks great to me they got some
great set pieces I really lutely I just
got hurled off the castle wall I was
awesome alright lasercorn give us
another one your cream of the crop from
e3 2016 what's right up there what's
something that's just gonna be there I'm
gonna give you one that surprised me
because i'm not a huge legend of zelda
fan but breath of the wild is really
looking good like yeah someone who
didn't i didn't play Skyward Sword you
know I played ocarina of time and a
little bit of majora's mask but I didn't
play Skyward Sword and I was waiting for
something to pull me back in and I feel
like this is that game it's just a huge
world it and it feels really fun like
they've set up like I was playing the
demo a little bit well first of all the
trailer looked awesome because it showed
actual gameplay and the stuff you could
do and I was playing the demo and there
was like a rock set up and I pushed it
down and this camp of what do they call
Boko fulcrum yeah I don't know i'm sorry
i missed the day little goblin thing yet
God look at they had these like dynamite
things set up at the camp and I'm just
watching from this legends this Boulder
rolls in and explodes and blows them all
up and then I went and I stole their
steak that they were cooking and I'm
like I feel good about this it's it has
that feeling that kind of like this
GTA may I am feel and you don't that
doesn't seem like a connection that you
would ever man right he's talking about
driving a boulder on bad guys I'm like
when didn't wink become a badass savage
right like the trailer shows he's like
jumping slow-mo through the air shooting
explosives and blowing everything up and
I'm like go on Nintendo / be able to
have like what seems like a violent
badass moment but still very card you
don't break spots yeah yeah over here
papi he will never stop hating like
pottery yeah i mean that that truly is
the story of The Legend of Zelda is just
simmering hatred of pong yeah his
parents were killed by pots I don't know
this it was a similar Batman scenario as
a dark alley every time you know they
don't tell you about every time I hero
of time is called it's when plots have
struck down tragically the parents of
there are too many there's more pots to
human ratio a hero needs to rise a
balance must be restored lottery market
is saturated yeah another cool mechanic
I saw from this game as I was watching
Wes from Smosh games he was playing is
you can disarm your enemies and in
combat instantly pick up their weapons
and equipment and he come them
definitely yeah it's so right well I did
that I i disarmed an enemy I picked up
the weapon and you can throw your weapon
yeah yeah and so I just picked it up at
chuck it at his own way I found that out
the hard way because I had a sword I'm
fighting someone but then I was disarmed
and now i'm running around without a
weapon and someone's like you had to
pick up 11 i'm like i gotta run away you
have to pick up 11 I need to run away I
grab the sword I throw it on accident
like oh by the way you learn quickly in
this game normally you think red bad
blue good oh you have a color way around
in this one guy just one shot that was
really beginning yeah he was vicious
yeah it's this really frantic like
lethal sort of combat where you don't
feel like it's holding your hand really
it's like like joven said you can get
this arm you could disarm people and
stuff and it's nice to talk I love
talking about the combat cuz a lot I
think a lot of what people talk about
focuses on the open world and certainly
that is I mean oh you inspiring my
imaginations just like it caught feel
like it calls to me like every time they
show that like walking out on the
plateau world is just sounded front and
part of me though asks inside like all
right am I excited because this open
world seems really cool or am I excited
because it fine
finally seems like Zelda is making a
leaf is making a significant move
forward and is breaking out of some of
the some of the maybe restricting things
that they that have long been like
hallmarks of the series yeah yeah it's
like sometimes you gotta break out of
that a little bit well the legend of
zelda lore is very epic and though it
may not reflect in the games arguably i
feel like this really does show the
epicness to the legend of zelda so we
now have an epic zelda game in my
opinion we absolutely do i talked a lot
about games it's sort of we've seen
gameplay up substantial amounts of but
there were a lot of great game trailers
also at this show and s specifically the
one that's not a think will stand out
for me the Halo Wars 2 trailer mmm
that's right that was another thing that
was rumored and then showed up yeah halo
wars with the first one was interesting
because it was trying an RTS on a
console in a universe that I think it
worked very well for of and it had a
niche audience at the time it's like yo
yeah it's a it's an RTS on console and
it works it's good and I think seeing
this now and just how big it looks it's
such a great trailer the question is now
that it's probably gonna be on the pc
yes they probably will but we will we
see our korean overlords pick it up we
don't know oh good i do think that it's
part of the play anywhere program yeah
you know playing maybe that's when we'll
see ya mouse keyboard do you think we'll
see a pro scene for it do you think
there's a protein yeah possibly emerge I
don't I don't know man start out good
its valley are just seen is that real
feels real lean in the eSports it's what
it feels lean like it's League of
Legends is just dominating that kind of
a perspective that kind of strategy but
like you know in starcraft 2 of course
still pretty active but yeah I think
gaining a foothold in that eSports
community for Halo or sooo gonna be
super hard yeah you know Microsoft is
already pushing you know putting a lot
into having halo 5 just sort of getting
a foothold in that competitive scene
with the tournament's they've been
throwing in the past year so yeah so I
don't know speaking of gameplay we
haven't
at the beginning of the bethesda
conference when that MS DOS prompt
popped up and it's hyped in quake I lost
it man I remember having to launch the
game like that as a little kid trying to
figure out how you go through a
directory and launch a gator executable
oh my goodness but when that popped up I
got so excited and it's interesting it's
going to be weird to see it look it
sounds like it's going to be one of
those heroes shooters or you know
following in the footsteps of overwatch
and law breakers and stuff so it'll be
cool to see their take on it but I'm
just excited to see quick back in any
form yeah and also so we didn't see a
lot of gameplay but mass effect we
finally saw more and drama de yeah he's
a little bit more but then when I was
such a tiny morsel yeah me more which
also goes into like for me III
disappointments I feel like this is III
this is where you bring your a-game and
you drop information and I feel like EA
did not do that at all in any of the
presentations but watching that trailer
now being able to see more of this world
what's going to be familiar what's going
to be new and just it reminded me why I
love Mass Effect and why it's my
favorite franchise and I can't wait to
jump back into bear world the only pitch
that I had to hear for that game was its
mass effect on frostbite I was like okay
yep yes please yes that moment towards
the end of that presentation when you
know really becomes clear like this is
Mass Effect Andromeda because they're in
a whole new galaxy and you sort of see
the big sort of cavernous ship that they
must have traveled there on in the
protagonist sort of wakes up with a
start like Brees real heavily and says
we made it and they like to start the
game I like having completed just like
this epic unprecedented long-term space
travel just seems like such a great
dramatic found age you could hear
everyone's hairs on their arms standing
up as a sound that went in the other my
question for you then because it does
seem like it's expanding from where the
universe we were in math like three will
we get a remastered one two and three to
replay through
so that we can recreate this universe
and have cars our decisions that our
save files go through you know I feel
like they I feel like the original
trilogy of mass effect is that is really
about Shepherd's story and they add
Andromeda they want this this is a new
story right this is a new adventure I
would be very surprised if they if they
carried the line through really I mean
well there's so many there were
decisions that you made that affected
the universe like with the rachni yeah
or the decisions you made with the
krogan yeah there could be an entire pro
game war happening that beak is because
the Shepherd's story that could affect
the andromeda universe sorry we want to
talk about some aspect lower for a while
oh I like it because those were those
decisions that was why it was such a
good such a priority to like let me get
my save through because part of that I
mean part of the mass effect thing is
this is my shepherd hmm this is my
shepherd she is the bomb she has made
these decisions identify with her I I
really think that they want I want a
clean slate roof later but maybe I think
what you might see is maybe you no
illusions you'll encounter some like
references to stuff that happened I you
know it's like I'm of the river invasion
yeah yeah they will don't connect those
threads so you feel connected but in
terms of your personal decisions I would
be very surprised if they brought back
the trilogy for the purpose of like
speeding people in for the purpose of we
should still get that humility remaster
don't want it again that should have
been announced because everyone's
remastering their games right now
android said it's like the trend that
we're in right now I feel like that
trend is here to stay in to the next
console situation and beyond that's true
I'm agreein felis some choice selects
III 2016 folks we are going to move on
to talk about some more hot III topics
in just a moment here on the game spots
co-op stage be back shortly
you